[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are beginning what we're
considering a series not a week week
after week series but a series that
we're going to be revisiting
throughout the year maybe years but
starting now
called our friendship throughout the
years and we're starting today by
talking about our friendship in
elementary school
the very beginnings i'm excited about
this because i mean
at this table we've shared many memories
it is a table over the episodes over the
years
of our shared experiences since meeting
in first grade but
i think this is gonna this is gonna
unearth
some new stories
and
it's a new lens through which to kind of
look at all of our memories specifically
the nature of our friendship
you know i think that there's kind of
this oversimplification
of the story of hey we've been best
friends since first grade
and
you just kind of
you
you picture us just kind of going
through life together but when you start
to dig into the specifics of it
again there's lots of memories that
maybe we haven't accessed or told
but there's nuances to our friendship
and it it definitely
has evolved over time and it's it's
changed with each phase yeah so we'll be
talking about
you know our first perceptions of each
other we'll be talking
most i'm most excited about
giving you the as true as possible
version of that first day that we met
and the story that we have told uh that
has become such a part of how we
introduce ourselves to
people and interviews and stuff like
that but i think that
and the further back you go so this is
as far back as we can go to the
elementary school years um
the more that we kind of gloss over
things because it's like i mean who's
who is interested in there hasn't been
an occasion for anyone to be like
let's talk about that in more detail and
so this is stuff that we haven't even
really talked a lot of this is stuff we
haven't talked about together that we've
never even reflected on yeah because
this is the the challenge with us is
we've been through so much together and
we've talked about so much of it that we
start having to find new ways if we want
to go back and access old memories
find new ways to talk about it and find
new memories to to explore so this is a
new
sort of
rubric i don't use that word very often
if at all rubrics cube
nope
i'm gonna i'm gonna open up rubrics cube
and uh
talk about what i used to think about
lincoln but the plan is yeah every
i don't know every month every six weeks
or so we'll pick up where we left off
and look at our friendship through the
next phase
you know middle school high school
college
uh young and married yeah young and
married young and wild
and then we get to old and wise or old
in whatever way eventually it'll just be
us talking about our current friendship
oh yeah oh yeah and i think every phase
will be juicy but let's start with
something really juicy oh man that i
question whether we should even do this
yeah we did discuss
but
whether we should get into this
but you know what
i feel like this is i mean it's dimly
lit for a reason there's a there's a bit
of a a secretive trust exercise going
here so you're in the
you're in the inner circle you're
telling
don't tell anyone you're telling anyone
who's listening to not tell anyone i i
feel like this is a special space where
things are discussed that hey if you're
into that you're here for it and if
you're not you're missing out
so
once we go through this thing i do want
to talk about the stipulations within
which we handle the information that
we've put out there
now
okay okay uh as
as as a group as a collective but we've
mythologized our first meeting
so much over the years that i think
well we've decided that we're going to
scrutinize this story like from a like
as if we were a detective yeah so if we
were a police detective who was trying
to like uncover what actually happened
so first let's tell the story
now we could also sing the story because
at some point
we wrote a song i actually think writing
that song contributed to some of the
simplification
so
on the here's how it goes
every single interview even to this day
next week if we have an interview with
somebody for a publication
we will say
on the first day of first grade we were
both held in from recess
writing nasty words on our desks
i wrote
hell
and i wrote damn i'm not really sure who
says what yeah sometimes we don't say
that yeah we'll say yeah and that's when
we met our teacher mrs locklear hello
from recess
and made us let's just say it together
color pictures
of mythical beasts
and that's when we hit it off and that's
why our company is called mythical and
that's why everything we do is called
something mythical and that's why our
fans call themselves mythical beasts yes
because of that origin story and you
know what we've been best friends ever
since
you don't want to ruin it for everybody
do you here's the thing when we started
talking about this recently
you okay
i'm gonna say something that i believe
is true about you and that is
you have an uncanny ability to
look back on something and change the
detail and then believe it to be true
and just and bypass the whole like ah
this is probably not exactly what
happened like because there's lots of
things that you've said and i'm like but
you know that's actually not like that's
actually not true right you that's the
way that you've
categorized it and smoothed it out in
your mind i've always had feelings about
this
story and then explain it okay i think
yes you're on to something
you're on to something but so let's just
break it apart
we did meet and first of all that we
have not discussed this at length no
it's not like we're about to confess
something to you that we've concluded
that we've been lying to you this is a
legitimate exercise right now
in your presence of us analyzing this
mythologized story
so
we certainly i have analyzed it on my
own a few times but certainly met
in first grade in ms locklear's class in
1984 in bowie's creek and we were
certainly both there the first day we
were definitely both there the first day
now
i'm going to go back to what i remember
i'm going to try to get back to what i
actually remember
i
remember both of us getting in trouble
and i remember both of us being held in
from recess
and i remember both of us coloring
pictures
and i know and judge and looking at how
you were coloring and making a judgment
about it very
an early accounts
of
that story
included the memory from me
of again now i'm just remembering the
remembering of the memories which is
what humans do anyway this is well but
i'm going back to what i think is our
core because because there's a couple of
things
but there's a couple of things about
that that i'll get into i i remember
paul bunyan and babe the blue ox like
there was a point when i
accessed that as what i believe to be a
core memory of what
we were coloring or i was coloring
i now that memory came from you yes the
fact that it was from it was paul bunyan
because i don't remember what we were
coloring
um
i mean so i i don't have an opinion
about that here's here's what i believe
to here's if i if you put me up against
the wall here's what i believe
i don't think it was the first day of
first grade okay i don't think that we
were i don't think we got in trouble on
the first day of first grade like a
simplification i think what happened was
we
we it's safe to say
that we met in some form because you
pretty much in some form you meet
everybody in your class on the first day
of
first grade yeah yeah and that's when
you moved from california i was there in
kindergarten you weren't
you know and i remember that on the
first day of first grade
but then at some point
we both got in trouble
well i know we both got in trouble
because i you know but back in the day
they used to give the uh i could see the
numbers on conduct
and it was the higher the number the
worse it was
and if it was a and four was the worst
and i always got fours
and it but the reason i always got four
talkative it's because i just wouldn't
shut up
self-control
hard to believe i got good hygiene that
i yeah they used to rank your hygiene
was on your report card yeah i'm sure i
did great on that yeah
i want to talk about that a little bit
hard to believe that i was a i was
talking boisterous at that age because i
was
when i accessed my feelings from that
time thank you therapy
i access a lot of timidity
and
early anxiety
uh so it didn't it didn't didn't
manifest it so we'll talk about first
impressions me becoming a cut up but
here but a couple of couple of things
later
if you if i had to bet
and part of this is influenced by the
fact that when we met miss locklear when
we tracked her down for our documentary
looking for miss locklear which you
should watch even though yes you know we
found her is still the spoiler is still
worth it it's only an hour long
um
she told us and this was not captured in
the uh documentary captured but we
didn't decide because we didn't put it
in it yeah we edited it out
she was like now we weren't comfortable
then like we are now and just
at no point had i thought that the thing
about being held in from recess together
was made up no
but she said
i really doubt that i held y'all in from
recess because i've never done that as a
punishment
and we were like
well we're going to edit this out yeah
yeah yeah but i'm going to document but
i was like
but i know but like i believe that to be
true like yeah and that was a there's
memories pre
being a
nasty word public figure
uh like
you know when you have to like answer
questions by people
reporters and stuff like that or you're
simplifying things and you're you're
you're an entertainment act at that
point
all bets are off you're going to like
massage things and you're going to tell
the big fish story and the story's going
to be this big but back before when i
was just remembering things on my own
and we were remembering things as
friends i was 100 sure that we were held
in from recess yeah and we were coloring
we weren't we were doing some interviews
for local papers but it was you know and
we were
maybe there was a temptation to massage
the story for the documentary
or to simplify it but no we absolutely
believed i cannot remember i don't have
i cannot visualize
getting in trouble
but
i know in my heart of hearts that we did
get in trouble but i'm 100 sure this is
something i would
bet everything on
we were not being held in from recess
for writing profanity on our desks okay
but we were we believed we were being
held in from recess even though miss
locklear said she didn't i believe that
i never did i believe that she did that
so it's like if if we weren't held in
from recess we were punished in some way
that i think it's it might have been a
succinct way to say it was
we were held in from recess that's a
that's a more visceral way to sit
a a picture to paint
than just oh we were punished and we had
to color pictures like the two of the
scene
that
everyone's out everyone's outdoors and
we are in the room just the two of us
i am willing to say
that might not be true
okay but you gloss over something
mr neal
you glossed over the pu what we were
being punished for i'm saying i am 100
oh no i'm saying that's the next thing
out of whole cloth yeah we made up the
writing profanity on our desks
we
for a while we said we didn't remember
what we wrote here's what we did and
then we just added what we did right
here's what we did i agree
he did not
i do how do you feel right now i do you
feel deceived we wrote profanity on our
death because we neither one of us would
have ever done that not right you you
wouldn't have defaced things hell no
just out of personal presence damn no i
would not have to face things out of
fear of being murdered by my i've never
defaced anything
in a graffiti-esque type of way in my
entire life yeah i was like i couldn't i
don't think i could bring myself to do
it now i mean ironically we invite
people to do that when we
invited them but it wasn't you know we
invited them to yeah yeah but yeah i've
never done it i would have never done it
100 confident that that's made up not do
that but here's my defense
what we said at first was most likely
something to the effect of
because because the reporter will ask
well you know what were you
what what what did you do
and we're like well we probably wrote
some words on our daughter probably
wrote something probably i made
something right now versus talk i
remember that the desks had writing on
them
from previous generations from other
people
and and that is something that you would
have gotten in trouble for i think that
happened during the song by the way the
song composition i think we probably
said something like before the song you
know what
we were probably scribbling on our desks
like oh and then the report is like what
were you writing and we're like well we
got to come up with some it's like oh i
don't know we we might have been writing
profanity you know it was probably just
like couched and hypothetical that then
the next time we told the story it was
like you know what that that was a
better story
we're gonna keep it catching
hypothetical but we're gonna tell it
more succinctly and then over time the
succinct ability of it removes the
hypothetical well and i think here
here's my defense here's my defense of
how this happens okay
and i honestly i don't have any idea how
people are perceiving this right now if
they're like their whole if they're like
disappointed i don't know what it is but
like
i've always seen the story of how we met
as like a comedy routine that is based
in something that actually happened but
like no stand-up comedian who tells the
story is telling you something that
happened to them exactly the way that it
happened to them they are taking what
happened
and then they are mythologizing in a way
to make it funny and entertaining
because their job is not a historian
their job is a comedian right is this
argument
and so i don't fully buy it but now but
no but now but so i mean but it is when
a standard comedian is like listen on
the way here and that's a lie okay if
they say that something just happened to
them today
100 of the time it did not happen to
them that day okay
if you if you live in a world and by the
way if nobody watches the late the late
night shows anymore but if you go on the
late if you're on the late night show
and all of a sudden the actor has like a
funny story
um
that's all rehearsed okay it's not like
they're just like you know what what you
just said jimmy just made me think of
this thing it's all rehearsed sorry if
that if you didn't already know that but
um i think that this is this is the
entertainment version of rhett and link
having a
cool packaged story that is largely true
largely but embellished to a point to
make it snappy and funny yeah and i mean
and at least we're coming out and saying
that's the case and i do think there's
an there's an evolution of the
hypothetical to
just leaving out that the phrase of the
hypothetical is just a thing of rhythm
that i'm very good at doing i'm just
like you know what this is a this is a
better way to tell the story
it still feels hypothetical and then
after a while it stops feeling
hypothetical to me here's the best
example of that just as a little aside
we'll come back to the origin story
because this has always cracked me up
yeah so
you know our story after we graduated
from college we were engineers for a
while and then we went on staff with
campus crusade for christ the
missionary organization that we were
involved in as students right so we were
like college
missionaries for a couple of years going
around
telling people how to tell people about
jesus right
and
so but in order to do that if you're
going to go on staff or crew you have to
raise support which means you have to go
and ask people for money like sit down
with individuals and families you do a
presentation
you go to somebody's home and you break
out your laptop you do a little
presentation and you say so would you be
interested in giving
us or supporting our mission 100 a month
or something like that yeah i had to
explain why the two of us were gonna be
we're gonna be
speakers and
seminar creators and resident comedians
and filmmakers
like how do you make sense of that right
well you talk about the stories from our
past of how we did that right we did a
lot of that yeah yeah but the evolution
of how it came about was like right at
the time we were raising support was
when me and you had become like a comedy
duo who was like making stuff together
and singing together and doing
conferences and stuff like that but
during college i was emceeing with greg
as a sidekick and then you were leading
the worship team yeah and we weren't
doing comedy together we would make vid
we would make the videos together like
you would like film the videos of me and
greg and stuff but like that's too
complicated to explain to a 65 year old
dude who's just sitting there falling
asleep and just wants to hear you tell
people about jesus you know what i'm
saying so you simplify i understand the
motivation great i became greg in the
story slowly over time but i but but my
theory is is that after telling that
story a few times you believed that to
be the case and christie did too
because she was there
she never said you know what that's
that's the story's changed
you know greg used to be in there now
you're just greg too
if we get a chance to talk to greg uh
about this yeah we we need to but okay
but back to the story so you were saying
that the
so i don't think it was the first day i
don't think
miss locklear doesn't think we were held
in we know that we weren't writing nasty
words on the desk we don't know what it
was i think we got in trouble but i
think that the coloring
was maybe not the punishment but we i
have a visceral memory of
sitting down and watching you coloring
right next to you
always in my mind was just the two of us
in the classroom
but i believe the f the only real fact
that i could defend is that i once sat
next to you and colored
and made observations about the nature
of the way you were coloring and i was
like wow he's like really precise it's
like going on what does he try like
i remember thinking like
what's he trying to prove
it was like because because did i prove
because first grade you know what i'm
saying first grade is like most kids in
first grade are just like they're
holding this is what i was doing you're
holding the crayon like this like you're
holding it like
you're gonna kill somebody you're gonna
like stab somebody with a crayon and
then it just makes contact with the
paper and you just move it and i'm just
like yeah yeah yeah yeah and then look
me not know what wheel is and you're
like
it's like really even i'm like wow is he
is he submitting this to a contest
because i didn't know this was a contest
and now i need to try you know i'm
saying oh no this is just art time i'm
not i'm not interested in this
uh but i know that that happened but i
i'm not willing to
stand by the fact that that those two
events coincided and it was actually why
we were being punished well it sounds
like at least three events have been
combined into one you remember
us coloring yeah we know we met
on the first day of first we had to and
we know we got in trouble at some point
at the same time
well i'm sure that that happened okay
so those three things were
compiled into one
mythologized
origin story
is there any other part of this that we
need to analyze or is that it
because i'm not going to if we're going
to come clean it's going to be now i'm
not going i don't want to come back to
this feeling
um at last
where it where it all started to fall
apart you know yeah right this is what
happens we came clean
it's all falling apart including our
friendship
i mean and from that point on so i'll
just move on then because i don't think
there's anything no from that point on
we were best friends and i think the
analysis of the rest of this episode
will
um
call that into question
well i i the only thing i'll say is
i'm not changing the story at this point
i'm not okay oh yeah i i i want to
establish how for all of you listen to
all the origins next time you're
listening to an interview or us talk to
somebody and tell this story we're going
to say the exact same thing we've always
said we're not going to change it and be
like you know really what happened was
is we just met in first grade we're
going to tell the entertaining
embellished mythology of our friendship
and we're going to tell it until the day
we die
and you know what
there'll be a little twinkle in our eye
because you'll know
the truth and nobody's nobody's getting
hurt
nobody's getting hurt okay
right
we're all what's it what's at stake here
what's at stake here right we're all in
this together if does it really matter
if if it comes out that it's all a sham
and it's not by the way we never said it
was
well it's an amalgamation shouldn't even
use that word amalgamation of truth
simplified into a compelling
narrative
and if you
want to
mess that up
well you're implicating yourself
[Music]
yeah okay but so we're trusting you
and we're going to keep telling that
story and i'm going to have a hard time
for the next year or so but then i'll
get over here i'll probably forget this
conversation here's something cool
here's something that i here i'll go out
on another limb here do it
and say that
if this you know
you should analyze how this makes you
feel
if you're listening to this
because what you probably should
understand is that the vast majority
of news and history
pretty much follows
what we're what what we did
not only that you ever read the bible
not only that i would say you're
take a hard look at your own experience
and your own
memories
your memories are a recollection of
memories every time you remember
something we've we talked about this
you're
reconstructing the memory in your brain
and if some and it evolves
yeah this is science
and this is science
um
we're all in this together like like i
was saying
and at least we came clean
we are so defensive right now i know i
just i feel good i feel good about it
well i think it was hilarious i feel
great i feel great we feel so great we
feel great i can tell that we both feel
great about it um we're so proud of
ourselves
it's it is canon let's talk a little bit
about this t-shirt uh you know i was
gonna put it on but i'm a little cold in
the studio right now
uh
i mean it looks good on the hanger this
is the hot dog is a sandwich uh podcast
t-shirt you know mythical kitchen they
have their own podcast hot dog is a
sandwich you know who else josh and
nicole josh nicole you know who else
has a podcast now trevor's got a podcast
of course he does trevor talks too much
yeah first episode where brittany
broski's already out as of the release
of
this episode right now fresh
uh listen to trevor talks too much
he's
he's good at talking
right off the right r right from episode
one
very proud of him very yeah he's great
glad that we've done it he's got the
gift of gab
taking full credit for everything he
accomplishes over there trevor talks too
much
hot dog is a sandwich expanding
offerings of
mythical podcasts
get in where you fit in you know i would
like to talk a little bit about first
impressions as i remember them okay
we've already talked a little bit about
my impression of like how you're
coloring
but and i actually didn't i had to kind
of dig back and think like what what do
i remember thinking about link
in meeting him now i've already
established that my
mo
was to
i was i wasn't i didn't perceive you as
timid
but i know that i definitely was not
timid in terms of my i threw myself at
people right
in a way that i don't do now like i'm
more of an introvert but i was a weird
extrovert in like elementary school in
the way that i would just like
meet somebody and then within the first
five minutes invite myself to spend the
night at their house that night
i did with anybody
and
so
i was very drawn to now i'm wondering if
everything you're saying is an
oversimplification like the first time
you met him you'd invite yourself over
that's an oversimplification it is but
very very early like alarmingly early
usually in the first day
i would be like hey so like uh
what do you think about sleepovers i
don't know i would i it's just i'd find
a way
to that's all true
um so i was but i would you know i was
kind of evaluating like oh this person
seems
there's something here like this person
seems like they'd be fun or like we
could have a good time together right so
obviously i thought that about you
because i'm pretty sure we had
sleepovers in first grade
but here's the thing that i remember
about you i find that hard to believe
okay maybe maybe this seems really early
for me okay
i remember thinking that you were very
clean
clean speaking of hygiene that you were
like very put together like you had this
like
your hair it was like it's like
somebody's like he's really he really is
caring about
like his hair and his clothes somebody's
coming
his hair is combed his his
his clothes like match like someone is
like
laying them out or he's cares about it
like you know i'm wearing like
gray sweat pants and a gray sweatshirt
you're like that's an outfit i'm there
you know what i mean and like you're
like i don't have a blue coke shirt and
yellow coke pants and like you know what
i'm saying and not i know this wasn't
just first grade but i remember thinking
that
it was like
but i didn't process it you know i'm
first grade so i i'm looking back and
thinking that like what did you think
about do you remember
like
even on the first day of a grade
would would you
i mean early on would you be in first
grade would your parents put you in an
outfit and take your picture
no
yeah every every year
um i would i would be putting an outfit
and my mom would take my picture with
like my new trapper keeper and my
lunchbox and i'm standing in front of
the closet and you know i'm going to
school and boy this is really built up
and i don't know how i feel about it i
think my parents were just happy my my
anus is very tight right now oh gosh i
think my parents were just happy
to get us to school without someone
dying you you had an older brother too
it was just like this is old news to
them
yeah the sweat just put on your sweats
it's like what are you gonna do you're
gonna go out and you're gonna play some
b-ball and i had and i had a i don't
know if in first grade i didn't have a
buzz cut in first grade but like
it pretty early on i was just like
they're just like just hit into the
barbershop and put it on level one like
me and my brother just had ones just
it's like it was like a military family
but it really wasn't it was a family
that didn't
care about
just like okay well you go to school
like we're gonna care oh we care what
you look like when you go to church and
we care what you look like on picture
day sorta
sorta but not really yeah for me it's
like you know
i was an only child and it was like you
know my mom
was like i was her little baby so like
she's like doing you know she's like
everything's got to be right for for
little
you know but for you it's like you're
the second and it's
there's also two opinions in your house
so it's like even if you're
if your dad wanted to dress you up and
your mom was like oh don't worry about
it let him wear his sweats or vice versa
i'm sure my dad was not right
my dad was like i'm just giving you know
no i'm not trying to play into gender
stereotypes here
but i'm just saying
there were there you're there's two
opinions
and those opinions are distributed over
two boys
whereas me it's one opinion that was not
throttled my mom's opinion
that i
did not question i was like okay yeah
it's like oh this is how things are done
i also think it's a disposition too
because sure we actually think about
like
jesse and i have both had probably more
opinions than we should have about like
what our kids wear when they go when
they go places you know what i'm saying
i think it might just be oh yeah just
like living in a more superficial
culture or whatever but it's kind of
like hey bro like
that doesn't match or like you your hair
looks crazy right now
those conversations didn't happen in my
home
you know what i mean
it just didn't it just just that wasn't
a part that i remember it doesn't it
wasn't a part of things it was kind of
like yeah you're dressed and you're
alive
i'll tell you what get out it wasn't a
part of my life and that was a part i
know that my hair
was just combed straight
it was come straight forward yeah and
there was no
but it was combed
i brushed i remember thinking
his hair looks like it's cut by a lady
as a total
yeah a total generalization yeah it was
and now her her name is not rudolph
blanchard
her name was bobby though so oh really
she didn't have a man's name okay
but um but she like no one she was a
woman scissors did not see my hair
until
30 the age of 30.
i mean i went through my whole 20s
cutting my own hair with a wit with
clippers i mean like
but scissors i could see you you you
were you had scissors on your hair i
think it was all it was written all over
your face i'm trying to think what my
first impressions of you were because i
i i have to kind of interpolate from
from the facts that i know
i i don't
and maybe i'll access a memory but
nothing specific comes to mind like it
does for you it's like i'm so good i
made such a strong impression on
so many visceral in specific memories
but it wasn't but it but because it was
different that's what i'll say that like
i felt like most of the other kids sort
of seemed like yeah like
we're in first grade
we're just
we're just kind of like going with it
existing yeah but it was like oh this
kid is like he's put together it's
picture day every day for this kid but
yeah yeah yeah
yeah right
yeah yes definitely
and for the reasons that i mentioned i
think that um
you know it
i don't think it was anything that i
analyzed it was just the the opinions in
my life basically my mom but you don't
think that i never questioned it you
don't think that you i never looked
around i don't think i was i was
self-conscious i do have this early a
preschool memory of like
i was
the guys were so rambunctious
and
physical like there was like wrestling
happening in preschool
and
i was afraid of the guys and i would i
would always hang out with the girls
like the guys would climb this
um
fort
structure
built indoors at the
lilington first baptist church and be up
there and i would
in doing rambunctious stuff and i was
just intimidated and so i would hang out
with the girls but and
no i didn't so there's no kindergarten
version of that i didn't know you at
that time but what i do remember along
those lines is that it was a very
quickly he's not he's not interested in
sports now again i wasn't
i didn't have a uh
i've never really been that like
j i'm not a judgmental person you know
what i'm saying so it's so so it's not
like he's not interested in sports so
therefore he's not my friend like no
that kind of thing does that happen it's
apparently it was he's different i gotta
see his house yeah i gotta spend the
night
like but it was clear that like even in
first grade i remember in first grade
first second grade
talking to other boys about you know
like j.r reed's coming to carolina like
that's a con that's a level of
conversation that i would have with
these other kids who like cared about
college sports and like what was
happening at carolina and state and duke
at the time right and a lot of that
comes from the fact that like okay my
dad was really into sports and all these
other kids dad's really into sports and
having a brother and that kind of thing
but it was like that wasn't a
conversation i was going to have with
you doesn't it was like okay well i'm
going to have a different conversation
with this with this guy my first
impression of you had to have been
related to the fact that like you
weren't there the year before
in kindergarten you
were you were taller than everybody yeah
you had this you had this
look about you it looks like you know
uh i'm a mess i'm not gonna look like a
falcon i'm not gonna say it's golemesque
but you have bigger eyes
and you were gangly and if you did just
say if you got down on all fours i'm not
gonna say that's
like
you know how in like
the fellowship of the ring they had they
put gollum in there for a few seconds
but you didn't really like they hadn't
fully figured out who gollum
was they hadn't done all the cgi so like
in two towers he's fully fleshed out and
looks looks different but in like the
first one he's kind of like
the shadowy new character that you don't
really know and like boy he's really
hunched over and you can kind of count
all of his vertebrae and boy there's a
he looks like he has some extra
vertebrae and his eyes are so big you're
talking probably what i thought we're
talking about i'm not going to say
because i don't remember you're talking
but factually that's not true because i
i looked that way
during and shortly after puberty
i actually was just kind of a tall kid
but proportionately relatively normal
okay i began looking like gollum ninth
grade i was just joking
okay well it's good joke
um
it's a good run there now it's worth the
90 seconds that it took let's go
i'm sure i wasn't the only one who
thoroughly enjoyed it
uh so we were let's go through the
teachers we had
from from first to sixth grade
first grade
miss locklear's class
second grade
i was in miss bailey's class
i was in miss lawrence's class so we
were not in the same class right
um and we can revisit some of these but
i just kind of want to go through it
third grade was a miss hood's class we
were both in miss hood's class
i mean i remember you being in music
yeah yeah you remember me being in mrs
yeah yeah and that's when ben and that's
your ben moved into town from oklahoma
okay third grade um
so
i remember really liking miss hood's
class michelle was great she was tough
but she was great a great teacher um
fourth grade miss everhart i was in miss
rand's class right yeah now
what happened was
um
they did this thing where it was like by
this age all the all the kids knew that
they were labeled
as
like some kids got this a.g label
academically gifted right and there was
this
it was a
it was something that everybody knew and
it was
it i don't think it was healthy that we
all knew it no and so then you were kind
of put into different classes
based on that i was like oh you're in
the smart class or you're in the not so
smart class miss everhart was the smart
class miss rand was the not so smart
class right um and you're right we all
kind of like we all knew it you all knew
it
and
the reason why
i was a smart kid i think i was i was in
that buck the ag bucket
uh
no judgment to those who weren't i guess
maybe i'm i don't want to imply that but
my mom
had heard all this stuff about how miss
everhart was so tough on her students yo
she gives so much homework she's so she
pushes him so hard that my mom went to
school and requested that i not get miss
everhart
and then her heart was actually an
incredible teacher i know it's the sad
thing about her room was out in one of
those trailers
yeah she was isolated so she could get
away with all types of stuff my mom
wouldn't want didn't want little linky
to to have to and suffer and the smart
kids by the way got a computer
did you all have a computer in your
classroom uh-uh yeah we had like two
they gave two they gave us two computers
and they gave you all zero computers
i'm sorry man your mom screwed that one
up big time i
and that was the year i learned my
multiplication table and i learned how
to beat oregon trail i yeah i didn't get
to play i had to go to the library to
play oregon trail yeah i could do it
anytime i wanted
um
man i i remember well i'd
i'm not going to talk i'm not going to
talk about my teacher but it was like
yeah the classes it just wasn't the same
caliber caliber
fifth grade
i was in miss hobb's class and i
couldn't remember if you were in there
yeah
the my big thing about that year my
claim to fame was that's when i won the
the anti-drug poster contest
and had to travel with miss hobbs to the
kiwanis club dinner at the western
sizzler and done we haven't given the
update i'm not going to do it now but
just as a reminder we haven't given the
update about what we learned about
we met someone who knew about your the
the posters contest
i need to get the full story and report
back from cole yeah from my brother my
brother brother met someone who was in
charge of choosing the winner of that
contest the other thing i remember oh
wow the other thing i remember from miss
hobbs was
she was pregnant that year and and lots
of times she was not in a good
headspace i remember her seeming a
little bit uh
perturbed with the children yeah
yeah she had a short fuse
and a and a a very pregnant belly yeah
it's like i in retrospect i kind of feel
for it oh yeah
i was like what is wrong with this woman
i mean i know that she's pregnant but i
mean what's her problem she was now she
was a good teacher though gosh she was
she was a good teacher learned a lot of
math in that class yeah
and then in sixth grade i was in miss
campbell's class i was in miss lanier's
class and at that point i really feel
like i missed out on miss linda's class
but miss campbell was super sweet it was
a combination class so there were some
uh it was the smart sixth graders and
the not as smart 7th graders yeah right
that's it that's really how it works
um pretty simple you know it's i we
haven't thought
really thought about it in a while that
like
every we met in first grade then every
other year
we weren't in the same class yeah
so and you have this memory of like from
the beginning
going on sleepovers to people's homes in
the book of mythicality
um if you're into this type of
conversation and you haven't
gotten your copy of the book of
mythicality get one because there's
stories that we're not going to share
here and lots of other stories um
from our from our shared best friendship
even though now we're dismantling it
um
available in audiobook form as well that
we read um probably even better um
i don't remember spending the night i
remember there i told the story of
spending the night at zach west's house
and then he he pile drived me
and uh
he wasn't
best friend material is how i put it in
the book i think i spent the night at
matthew enzor's house
once
and
like his dad benny was watching alien
and like i felt really uncomfortable
so yeah it's just like i just remember
feeling uncomfortable in other
environments like
i i was only comfortable at home so i
can believe that if you invited yourself
over to my house i wasn't going to say
no i would be like sure but i i would
not have been comfortable going to your
house at such an early age oh i didn't
invite people to my house
because i already know about that okay
so i didn't have sleepovers at my house
until
like
very few of these people probably sixth
grade maybe seventh grade yeah so okay
and that's when i would have started
spending the night at your house my
perspective on this is that
uh
again i
the way that my brain works is that
i i don't
especially at the time i didn't like
categorize people right and so
if you ask me in first grade who's your
best friend i'd be like i i got i got
lots of friends and i would probably
answered that question the same way
i would say that there's probably like
third and fourth grade after ben moved
into town yeah there was probably
especially that year um
the miss everhart year where we were not
in the same class yeah or i would have
said ben was my best friend if you would
have put me up against well but i but i
did not think maybe not and maybe not
and there's a reason i'll give in a
minute but i'm not surprised by this
yeah but it makes sense i didn't think
in terms of that it was more just like
there's people that i like to hang out
with but everybody oh like
if i mention any guy
tell me if you spend the night at the
house
adam
yeah
david r yes
uh
you didn't let's see who uh
the enzors did you spend my
mountain
not yet definitely at least a couple of
times but i don't remember exactly maybe
a little bit later
tate maddox oh yeah multiple times
uh
who who else
um
zach
you spent a night in zach's house oh
yeah julian
oh julian skateboarder yeah well he was
too intimidating
and i think chris too chris morris i
think so
uh of course peter peter dinklage not
the peter dinklage
well he was your neighbor so you'd walk
over he was younger too you would spend
a night at somebody a year younger you
got a house you got a fridge you got a
tv i'm there
oh justin
you'd go around the corner to justin's
house every kid in my neighborhood
was on the list
uh
michael jubie oh yes michael jubie had
the best house
he had that kind of lost a spiral
staircase with a spiral staircase he and
he was on a golf course oh yeah hole 13
at the time on keith hills man
and his parents his parents were fun to
talk to they're so cool yeah
man
i didn't spend the night at any of these
people's houses
ever
i was gregarious man i was up for a good
time that
when adam nicholson had that sleepover
for his birthday and we watched texas
chainsaw massacre that may have been the
first time i spent the night at anyone's
house and that was probably seventh
grade sixth grade
really yeah
i can name ten more by the way if you i
need a yearbook
okay
we won't get into it
you know brooks i don't okay so brooks
was younger too two years younger but he
was a family friend we were our families
were really
so and you loved it you were never like
get me out of here
no man i i
here's the thing
i
i i mean we're so different in this
world but this but it didn't register no
but this is something that i i didn't
know about myself and i've never really
thought about it
but like i
especially back in the day i don't i
don't feel like i do this as much
anymore but like i would find a way to
connect with somebody i'd be like this
is the thing that they're into and it's
just like i'm into everything so when i
go to this person's house all we talk
about is this and you know what i didn't
dictate what we talked about it was like
this person's into this this person's
really into nintendo well
i can be really into nintendo you spent
the night chad lander's house yes and
just played nintendo just like he would
do a speed run through it all uh i think
there was one i think one time okay but
it is funny because now that i've
learned more about the enneagram
uh
you know what they one of the things
they call the the enneagram three is the
chameleon right
it's a person who blends in can enter
into a
environment and immediately be like
this is what we're doing here all right
this is what i'm doing if that's what
makes everybody happy that's what i'm
going to do and that brought me joy and
you had a really stable
home life
you know i think and
i'm doing some work now to kind of go
back to that point and this is kind of
helpful like i'm not going to bring it
up here like i'm not going to bring
the therapy component into this except
to say maybe later but for now the only
thing i'll say is that like
yeah i'm coming to grips with the fact
that like um
you know
my mom did an excellent job i i'm not
critiquing anything she did with the
hand that was dealt her but it was not i
had this perception of it it was not a
stable
environment you know
and it and i had this really keen sense
of
like just
a gut feeling of
of
lack of safety outside of the home
um
that's an oversimplification and maybe
an over dramatization of it but it was
like that that's kind of how
i ventured into the world was with
trepidation yeah so
you know when you were spending the
night at people's homes like what was i
doing i was i was doing my own thing at
home like
watching
this new thing called nickelodeon on
channel 30 i didn't have cable that was
another reason i had to get to other
people's homes um they had cable and
then i would i would do ex i would do
some exploring in the woods and all the
stuff around my house
uh alone i would pretend to be
an army guy
who was like
and we had the so you remember those
duck boots that everybody had and on the
back of them they said explorers uh-huh
because i think it was like an addition
of that duck boot yeah so cole and i had
those and then jeremy fisher down the
the street
uh had those boots as well and so we
were the explorers but that was again
that was with
neighborhood kids yeah that was with my
older brother
older and so we were neighborhood kids
like name the forts and stuff like that
but like my community wasn't like that
we were on opposite sides of town
right so
but i think one of the main forces that
brought us together and it superseded
school
um
and then might change a little bit of
the complexion of like what would have
been in your mind as a fourth grader
saying that ben was your best friend
which you certainly would have said
uh
but would have kind of put me in that
conversation
was church
yeah um
you know from
from
from the moment you moved there you
joined blues creek first baptist church
the the church that me and mom and my
step-dad jimmy went to it was so we were
at that church why do you think your
parents chose that church
um
i think
i think jimmy had a connection to that
church that went further back so it was
like there was a
longer established connection there
but
and then
i was very we were both very involved
your parents were very involved
my mom
if she could if she could pull
everything together in time to get to
church on time she was she was going to
be there but she you know she had a hard
time getting ready
to the point where at a certain point
i'd be like mom you need to stop halfway
and you like in your like makeup and
hair routine to bring me to church
because the kids are making fun of me
for being late for church every sunday
morning for sunday school
and then she would come back and like
show up halfway through the sunday
school lesson or just show up at church
she could not get herself ready wow
um
but yeah we would
sunday school and church every sunday
morning every wednesday night there'd be
something and then there was usually
another
another night of the week that we were
at church so it was like even the years
that we weren't in the same class
we were we were spending
like our youth group time
church time together and like
so and and we were very close
in in that world like if you think of
everybody else that went to who were the
other guys that went to church with us
there wasn't like matthew mckinney went
to church with us
in matthew matthew matthew john enzor
but
so it was a smaller group that like we
were the we were the closest to yeah
yeah yeah yeah but by that time by that
time it was from an early time and by
third grade
third fourth fifth sixth grade
i would not have said that any of those
other
kids that i had spent the night with
were my best friends i would be like my
friends are ben and link yeah in terms
of like my friends my age and then and
then i would be and i think i would have
been like and i hang out with brooks
quite a bit sports yeah when you talk
about brooks sports was such a big part
of your life basketball
like
you played everything you played
baseball you played soccer i played
soccer from
that was the big thing in bowie's creek
everybody there was like a five six and
seven year old team recreation team like
they started you really young it was
like very organized that what basketball
recreation didn't exist yeah baseball
recreation didn't exist but like it was
interesting that soccer was the thing
that was like really exploding
in like the late 80s and so and campbell
had a really good team
that's right so like
i
i always played soccer and had enough
confidence to to at times
begin to enjoy it
but not any other sports but you were
into every sport so we didn't connect in
that way
but
i i played all the other sports all the
way through you know
uh up until
yeah like baseball started at like
maybe sixth grade and i did play boy i
hated that maybe fifth grade yeah but
so
a little bit of soccer but it was mainly
church
and like
your parents were so committed to it and
i kind of folded in underneath that like
level of commitment that was like i was
i mean as we've established from a young
age
you followed your parents example and i
kind of followed your family's example
of like being super committed yeah it
was like that was
from a very early age our identity
as people was our our evangelical belief
system
even in contrast to
the other church across town memorial
baptist and so oh they're the they're
the more liberal church and like we had
friends
from school who went to that church but
we thought of them differently because
it wasn't they weren't as uh
fervent in our opinion as we were i mean
that that's a whole story in and of
itself is just yeah the the uh there's a
saying for that the something of minor
differences i can't remember what it is
but it says you've got to have you've
got to have an enemy and in this little
teeny tiny town
there's two main churches that are two
baptist churches and those two baptist
churches have to find a way to look down
on one another it's just so crazy
because i mean read the lost causes of
bleak creek you'll see how we folded
that into the novel but
um
and there weren't many people we we
didn't have many classmates who didn't
go to one church or the other you know
so it was really that's why there was
such a dichotomy it's like everybody
went to one church or the other and we
were getting we were getting closer to
the group of of kids that were our age
that were were at church
as well and and and as we got older
you know
it you start taking it more seriously
and so then the fact that you take this
very seriously and like you believe in
god in this very particular way
and you practice that belief then you
start making connections with people and
also there's like the whole like you
start kind of drawing some political
lines because
that's part of it as well and of course
we're talking early 90s
south
by that time the christian right pretty
much taken hold in the conservative
party so republicans so it was just like
oh are you a democrat or republican
right so it's like you needed to be a
republican
christian
in order to be like really in on the in
club and that was beginning that was
starting to filter in the way that we
were thinking right yeah and i remember
even you know around like fifth sixth
grade
ben started to kind of experience some
of the
uh
some of the issues that the tension
because he went to memorial baptists
well but also he was always such an
open-minded like challenging thinker
because his family was and so it's just
like that started to get a little
complicated as i'm like getting serious
about this it's kind of like yeah it's
like your dad was a baby
not really into this like he's got ben
was a biology professor right yeah yeah
so it's like you know you can definitely
see that vibe
of like you know this
the the
the rule following verses but coupled
with the fact that ben was also
beginning to experience some emotional
things and and physical things like
trying to figure out is he got chronic
fatigue whatever i can't remember
exactly when that started to manifest
itself
but that began to complicate it's
difficult for kids to understand how to
navigate a friendship when someone's
going through stuff like that which
again will refer to the other podcast
that um
you know where we talked at length about
been our other best friend so we don't
have to get back into that now but i
mean we we certainly connected
over like being out in nature so even
though you spend a lot of time playing
basketball as we got into these these
older elementary grades
like
you were you were i was i was more
comfortable coming out of my shell you
know
ramping up into middle school and like
uh starting to get like we connected
over like being in nature and i got in
on what you and ben were doing but back
to the church thing
i mean
our our first teacher i remember was
miss
tolsma tollsome something like that [ __ ]
i do not remember her she was my
neighbor across the street and she she
was our sunday school teacher at first
she blinded had all the kids she had the
two twins who were blind twins good gosh
really the fantasies
the fantasies i don't going over there
and
swinging on a swing set with those
blonde twins that's all i wanted
i just wanted to swing with them i
didn't remember being into them
but that was kind of like a normal
scenario i feel like you had different
tastes mom and women but
my point is
she was a normal sunday school teacher
but then miss cluck showed up
okay now we're talking now i remember
miss cluck
you know had a son who was a year older
than a sam yeah yeah yeah and her
husband was he was a science guy at
campbell well they lived in that house
that like the camp not the campbell
house but near the campbell house where
like people who were in town working at
campbell would like live for a little he
was a professor but he had just they had
yeah somehow they just moved in there
was very associated with the school and
but she was very scholarly
and kind of this like
home school precursor type thing so like
when we went to her sunday school class
it wasn't just like hey here's a nice
bible story and
you're gonna have some some prayer and a
craft no this was intense
education
like this is what grace means this is
what mercy means this is how they don't
mean the same thing
and it's like posted all over the yeah
we were being indoctrinated real hard
and it was yeah she was very it was very
intense yeah
and she was a she was a
i wouldn't say how would i describe her
scholarly intense
proper like prim and proper it's kind of
like if she could have had a ruler and
smacked you on the hand it was almost
like if it was
you know a couple of decades earlier
old school vibe
um and again this is just
sunday school this is just an elective
thing but you know one of the things i
think is significant about this
is that
kids respond to this type of instruction
and let's just be honest this type of
indoctrination in different ways
some kids
sniff it out and are like i'm not into
this and they rebel at that point and
they kind of check out
even though our personalities were very
different
we both locked in on this thing and
we're like for whatever reason this is
it man this is important like i got to
listen to this these people i got to be
about this and i think that the fact
that we both
uh
latched on to it so hard
really brought us together that's what
made us such good friends yeah leading
into middle school even if we weren't in
the same class we didn't see each other
at school for every other year
that that's absolutely what did it
you know and and she was also artsy she
she didn't write it but she brought in
this um
play
the bible tells me so show mm-hmm and
that was her huh her yep her son sam was
like
like a gifted actor and singer and very
charismatic and like larger than life
but in retrospect i think it was okay
she can't cast her own son to be the
starring role of this
because the host of the show you know it
was the bible tells me so show was it
was a spoof of family feud
if family feud was just about bible
trivia yeah and then the two teams
that competed that which like the two
families
were
friend groups so it's like all the they
were like all kids in a youth group that
knew each other so there was like
some sort i wouldn't call it drama but
there was interplay friendship interplay
between that's part of the christian
interplay that's part of the story
that's part of the story that rounded
out it because we were all in the same
youth group
yeah
so she couldn't cast her own son to be
the star which he clearly needed to be
yeah as i recall that would be the case
um
and so she
cast me to be the host of the bible
tells me so show
i remember you getting that part
and this was at a time that i was like
any sort of like
i was about being like a class clown and
like you know cutting up and like
getting attention in that way i was too
and you were too but when it came to
like this is organized and somebody else
is dictating what this is i was always
like this is not for me
that's it because it was a play but yeah
yeah we like i had this we didn't think
we were the drama right right but i
remember you getting cast as that and
and it's like now i'm thinking back to
what i must have been thinking it'd be
like well you know what he is very clean
yeah like a host
yeah he's like he's very he's very put
together like this is a good this is
good casting
you know what i'm saying you don't want
to you're not going to give the kid with
the buzz the hosting job because she's
like you had like hair like you had hair
that could be like
combed into a and at east easter i would
wear suits to church
yeah you had a blazer at least one yeah
right yeah
i think this guy was pretty good casting
i think sam would have taken it to gone
too hard
he didn't would have gone too hard he
went so hard at everything
uh yeah so i mean you were in the play i
was on one of the teams all the youth
group were there but i had so good
answer good answer i had so many lies
that was one of my lines
and it was a musical
when i see trees
waving in the breeze you had to sing
that hear the
birds in the air i thank the lord for
all that he has done this amazing
remember this is me he cares you don't
remember that no man i don't remember
that dude oh give thanks to the lord for
he is this is why there's two of us
i remember certain things
he remembers him
and helps the reigns now hold on do you
think you could sing this without the
fact that you found it on video i found
the video i didn't watch it i remember
this stuff from then absolute freaking
loot really the thing that i it's crazy
and what i want to do is i'm gonna i
want to
digitize
the i've got this vhs it's got my mom's
handwriting on it she kept it all these
years and now i have it i want to
digitize the bible tells me
let's put it on the society and we'll
like do a director's commentary of well
we didn't direct it we'll get miss cluck
to do it no we'll do it we'll do a
participant an actor's
commentary
over this thing yeah yeah yeah that's a
good idea i think we we kind of have to
put it on the mythical society just
because that's where it makes the most
sense and there might be might be rights
issues other otherwise
um that's what the mythical site is
always all about man yeah it's about the
coolest stuff no that i remember all the
songs but i'll tell you what i don't
remember
any of my lines even at the time i
remember drilling my lines i had to i
had a stack of stuff i had so many
freaking lines weren't you at one point
in the baptismal
uh didn't the baptismal open up and you
said something i don't think so in my
mind that's what happened i had the
script on the pulpit
and i would flip the script and i'd
follow it along i couldn't memorize it
did we do that on a sunday morning
did they give us the service uh i don't
know maybe
like it come to this thing but it was
such you know there was
we were so
like the youth group was like so much of
our identity and like you said it really
brought us together
and it was like our youth group against
the world against like when we went they
would talk in terms of like when you go
into school it's like you support each
other and you hold each other
accountable but we but we were
developing this
incredibly tribalistic
mindset right
and and i'm using that in the term
in terms of
how hard you identify with another group
of people in an ideology to the point
that
um
in this tiny little town
where everybody pretty much thought the
same stuff to begin with yeah and again
they might think a little bit
differently about some things
but like
we
develop this mindset that we were
different even in this place that was so
different from everything else
and i we i just had no idea what was
happening in my mind it's like that is i
i'm so happy i was able to let go well
one of the things was pride just
thinking about you're the rightest of
the right of the right of the right of
the right we definitely took
pride in that and said okay
now i can through this lens i can
understand who i am
and when you find other people who think
exactly the same way
it
creates an incredible bond
you know and we'll talk about middle
school and high school in two other
episodes
um but yeah it's like
this being established feels it now like
in sort of that late elementary school
is what it's the reason that we ended up
staying such good friends through all
that and it's the reason that we went to
college together it's the reason that we
went on staff together it's the reason
that we're sitting right here at this
table so i can be kind of like i can
poke fun at it or i can say that it's
toxic in some ways but
we really owe
everything to the church
you know the bible tells me so
yeah it's the place to be yeah you'll
see catchy did she write that
i don't think she wrote any of it but
she she was capable of it
she's very capable i'm a little
disappointed you don't remember any of
the songs
i don't know how that's
i wish i could do i don't remember that
part of my brain any of our songs
[Laughter]
when we get ready to do a concert i'm
like give me a few days
[Laughter]
i have to reacquaint myself with every
part of this
but lines i mean
i don't know it's a different spot in my
brain i don't know
maybe i should be more into musicals now
and maybe i i could have a career in
music
it's you know what i thought about this
i don't think it's uh
music versus
lines i think it's your long-term memory
there's a part of your brain that stores
it really really effectively i have
really good short-term memory a very bad
long-term memory in terms of like lyrics
like that
so
i do think this sets up our next
conversation you know when we revisit
this and go into middle school i mean
because there's so you know there were
so many pressures that then of puberty
and
uh blood pressure and dating yeah
pressure in the pants
but pop that zipper
but there's different i think there's
maybe and we've explored some of that
but there's like other ways to look at
yeah we're not just going to talk about
it in high school
uh as we get back into that but i think
this i think there's a good start you
know i have a good appreciation for
how
it's a combination of so many
circumstances
and
like in spite of our differences
that brought us together it's like we
had these things that mattered the most
to us yeah that that brought us together
and there were the you know and the
amount of time associated with those
things and those priorities
uh really worked but i mean you
you could be sitting here with matt
mckinney or i
even more likely i could be
you know there were times because like
in the youth group
he was probably the other guy that like
at times like i really hit it off with
when you were you
your basketball mode
you know because he went to church with
us
like i don't know you know if there's
many other people that
you know once you get in like fifth
grade
that it could have been yeah but it was
but it was kind it felt kind of
pre-ordained too well and there was and
the thing i think we'll talk more about
it in the next one but like the things
that we were finding funny oh yeah like
is we didn't even get into that but like
we were connecting on the
how silly we were and the things that we
thought were funny and yeah and that was
that that was really the connection
between us and ben too like the three of
us
were so silly
to the point of like
this the level of silliness was it would
push other people off people like these
guys there's something wrong with that
yeah it was like they're their own
little club right of silliness like
weird to a tourist
it was inaccessible and i and i like and
i really liked yeah it's like yeah i'm
super into sports and i want to be the
best at all this
sports stuff but i want to be incredibly
silly and i and just com it's completely
unreserved like we were completely
unreserved when we
were being stupid and i and we i think
we did
that's the thing that we fully explored
in the book of mythicality that
that we really didn't talk about as much
here because those early uh
those early uh radio shows and the stuff
that we did that was all in elementary
school that was that was all very early
we were doing that stuff at my house
with the jam box it's probably not quite
as early as we think it was making sure
yeah well i'm probably fifth grade great
yeah but so to tie a bow on this
you know that the origin story is
at least parts mythology and then the
best friend since first grade it's like
well it's a little more complicated than
that there were some ins and outs and
some circumstantial things in the
elementary school years
but that as we were coming to the
elementary school years were coming to a
close heading into middle school
i think it was we would both safely say
that we were each other's best friends
and it's been that way ever since but
that's not as
clean just like a link nail bowl cut
right across the forehead
as saying
best for instance first grade
um
and you know what
this is a special it's kind of like
renewing our vows our friend our best
friendship valves that's another way to
look at this thing we can have a
ceremony okay um
and you know what there's another reason
this episode is special i'm not gonna
give a wreck this is our last recording
with kiko yes that's right kiko we're
gonna get a little sentimental with you
here man kiko joined us
about five years ago
and has been working exclusively on air
biscuits for about four of those years
right
so been here in the room
he has listened to us talk about so many
things and you know what he has to
listen to it
when we talk about it now and then he
has to listen to it again when he edits
it
and are you tired of us yet is that why
you're leaving
[Laughter]
so you got
you got a great job opportunity with
patreon and we fully
we fully bless
let's go churchy
we're giving you blessings
we're giving you blessings kiko we're
going to send you over to patreon and
then when you've had your way with
patreon we want you to come back into
the fold at any time you had your way
yeah it's like that's not really i don't
think i don't remember anybody saying
that in church at least the prodigal
kiko returns
now yeah we're first of all thanks for
everything that you've done you've made
this podcast uh uh what it is in a lot
of ways yeah thank you for protecting us
from things that we said that came out
wrong that you you you caught before
they went out
yes and patreon is lucky to have you and
i know that we will stay in touch and
you know what
it's it's
been truly inspiring to see you develop
professionally
and as a person like you know we count
it
uh an honor to know you and to have been
a part of your life and to kind of just
to see
who you are and you know
we appreciate the things that you've
said about
the impact that we've had and this
experience has had on you
and we want you to know that it
absolutely has gone the other way too
you've had a tremendous impact on us and
we will never forget it and we're not
going to forget you because we're still
going to be in touch but thank you for
everything that you've done
to shape this podcast
and also
to be an inspiration we've learned a lot
from you so thank you
yeah thanks kiko we don't give you a mic
so you can say anything
all right so we're but we're going to
keep doing this ear biscuits we're not
going to stop just because you're
leaving
all right
so uh yeah so yeah we'll speak at you
next week thanks to kiko good luck
uh we know he's going to be
successful wherever he goes yep
hashtag gear biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]